As we’ve covered before in our video on
What Happens to Undeliverable Mail with No
Return Address? the individuals tasked with
processing mail often go above and beyond
what is expected of them in their quest to
ensure that every piece of mail gets to its
intended destination.
And, at least in the United States, it would
appear that this admirable dedication to the
job includes sifting through letters that
have the correct postage attached to them
with tape instead of a stamp.
Yes, as weird as it may sound, in the United
States it is, in fact, totally possible to
send a letter by simply attaching money equal
to the value of the required postage for a
given letter and still have it delivered.
It's also fully possible to do a hybrid of
this where perhaps you needed two stamps for
a given letter, but only had one, so affix
one stamp and then some change to cover the
rest.
Unfortunately, the same does not appear to
be the case in several other countries we
looked at, such as the UK, or at least we
couldn't find any examples of people successfully
doing this, nor stated rules that appear to
allow it.
In fact, in the UK taping coins to an envelope
equivalent to normal postage for the letter
itself even if it was processed could see
whomever you were sending the letter to being
charged extra because any letter more than
5mm thick qualifies as a “large letter”
under Royal Mail rules and thus, requires
the sender to pay slightly more for the privilege
of sending it.
Moving back to Freedom Mail, to quote a the
Mailing Standards of the United States Postal
Service Domestic Mail Manual, part 2.3.3 Mail
Collection:
“Generally, mailable matter is collected
from a mailbox if postage is fully prepaid
or money equal to the required postage is
left in the mailbox.
Money in a mailbox is left at the customer’s
risk.
When postage or money is insufficient to cover
postage, the mail is not collected, or if
the sender cannot be identified, the mail
is treated as unpaid mail.
Mailable matter not bearing postage found
in, placed on, attached to, supported by,
or hanging from boxes is handled under the
applicable standards.”
There are some potential caveats here, however.
For starters, mail with the correct postage
in change attached instead of a stamp usually
needs to be sorted by hand, something that
will obviously result in the letter being
delayed somewhat.
Also, it’s noted that as much as mail workers
endeavour to find and process these letters,
sometimes, particularly if you dropped the
letter off instead of mailed it from your
own mailbox, they end up being processed by
the automated sorting machine which has a
tendency to chew up letters with foreign objects
attached to the outside of them.
So be wary of that too.
According to one time Post Office mail facility
manager Fran Eagle, the usual process when
dealing with letters with coins and the like
attached is to remove the money and replace
it with a stamp before simply feeding it back
into the sorting machine to continue on its
merry way like any other piece of mail.
This can, however, potentially create a problem
as, with some caveats, it is a federal crime
to knowingly open someone else's mail, something
that can easily happen by accident when removing
tape from a thin paper envelope.
As such, some postal workers may be wary about
trying to remove the change in some cases,
even if it is the correct amount.
In these cases, they may either send it back
to you or to the Mail Recovery Center (more
colloquially known as the Dead Letter Office).
As we’ve discussed in our article on the
subject, workers in the Mail Recovery Centre
are incredibly committed to their jobs so
there’s a good chance the letter will probably
still get delivered even if this happens.
Moving on, it turns out that the United States
Postal Service has a number of obscure rules
related to mail and postage that vary in accordance
with geography.
For example, if you live well outside a major
city and far from any suburb or the like,
your mail will in all likelihood be handled
by a rural letter carrier.
Due to the nature of their work, rural letter
carriers are granted a host of perks not enjoyed
by traditional mail carriers.
These include the ability to wear their own
chosen clothing and drive their own vehicle
if they so wish.
More relevant to the topic at hand, beyond
the perks, they also are empowered to function
as a sort of mobile post office.
For example, if you'd like to buy stamps,
just wait at your mailbox for the rural mail
person to arrive or leave appropriate funds
in the mailbox with a note of what it is for
and they'll generally happily sell you some.
They can also process Express Mail and Priority
Mail or do what's needed to help you mail
a package (even with insurance), sell you
a money order, and process certified or registered
mail, all essentially the same way postal
workers would do it if you actually went to
the post office.
As you might have guessed from all this, if
you simply leave the required money for postage
for a piece of mail in your mailbox, perhaps
in a separate envelope papercliped to an envelope
or Priority Mail item you wish to mail with
instructions on what the money is for, they
should happily process that for you the same
as if you'd gone to the post office to have
it done.
And, in this case, if you leave extra money
for a book of stamps, they should leave that
too.
The idea here being that people that live
out away from more populated regions often
have to drive a long way to get to the post
office, so they simply empower their rural
carriers to do many of these tasks right at
your mailbox.
Finally, at this point you might be wondering
how often people actually send mail with money,
instead of postage, attached.
It turns out not very often relative to the
number of letters processed daily.
According to USPS, they process approximately
187 million pieces of first class mail every
day, of which, only a couple dozen items per
day have money, instead
of stamps, attached.
Bonus Facts:
• Speaking of weird U.S. government related
services that a lot of people don't know about,
it turns out if you every find yourself with
a torn piece of money, say where maybe 1/3
of the bill is missing, you can just mail
it to the Department of Treasury with your
info and in most cases they will mail you
back a check for the amount of the bill.
That said, there are caveats, such as that
you must send in greater than 50% of the bill,
or if you don't have that much of it left,
must provide sufficient evidence to show that
the other part is destroyed.
• Given it is a federal crime in the U.S.
to open someone else's mail, with some shockingly
severe consequences if you're caught, you
might at this point be wondering if that one
time you accidentally opened your neighbor's
mail that was mistakenly left in your box
means you now may be facing a lengthy jail
sentence if you're discovered.
It turns out that, contrary to popular belief,
no.
There are exceptions in cases where it's reasonable
to assume you may have accidentally opened
the piece of mail, such as if found in your
own mailbox among many other letters where
you may open a series of letters without actually
looking at who a given letter was addressed
to.
That said, if you then throw that letter away,
instead of put it back in your mailbox with
a note like "return to sender" or "wrong address",
well, now you did just commit a crime via
intentionally obstructing the delivery of
U.S. mail.
Another caveat to all of this is if someone
gives you permission to open their mail, even
though you definitely in these cases know
it's not addressed to you, you have not committed
any crime in this case either, though of course
if you want to be completely safe, perhaps
best to get written permission if you don't
trust that person.